how did the opportunity to even be on
Big Brother come about it's interesting
it just came about about a week exactly
a week ago I got an email from from a
friend of mine and she said I got I was
reached out to you by a producer at CBS
and they want to know if you're
interested in doing Celebrity Big
Brother and you were like yes or you're
like hail No
well I'm a kind of person I stay pretty
busy and so if something comes up like
this and it fits into my calendar I
usually say yes okay are you nervous
about being confined in this house with
all these are the wackadoodle
celebrities yeah as a football player we
had training camp and you know 52 true
wackos and I managed to do that for 11
years so I'm good because when I was
reading up on you I read that when you
were younger you had some social anxiety
and so does that come to play at all in
Big Brother I don't think so I think
social anxiety was more outside of the
house we'll be inside the house and I
think I'm fine what is your biggest fear
is it giving up your cell phone is it
giving up your life you can't binge
watch your favorite TV series mmm I
think as a football player you learn to
try to be fearless and you learn to
enter a situation with an open mind and
and ready to take to deal with whatever
comes how competitive are you I don't
think I'm competitive in the
conventional way I'm more competitive
against myself and against circumstances
and always willing to adapt and adjust
whatever's whatever is necessary to be
successful a lot of times on these shows
people who commit to series like this
when they come out of the house or they
come out of the competition they realize
that oh my gosh all of America's fallen
in love with me and now all these
opportunities come is there any hopes
for you is there something you want to
do next in your career in the
entertainment world well the point this
is really the point the biggest I think
potential in doing Celebrity Big Brother
is that when I come out of the house
people will know who I am not just as a
football player but but Who I am and I'm
an astrologer and I'm a healer and part
of what I'm going through in my life is
a rebrand because the things I'm into
now are so different from from football
I love that so will you be doing
readings for everyone in the house I
hope so I mean it gives me a huge
advantage so - typically celebrities
like
to talk about themselves and to hear
people talk about them so I get their
their son sign and I can talk to him for
at least a couple of hours about
themselves
no memorise I do I mean I've been
studying for 15 years and it's a big
part of my life wow that's cool
some stars last year found it even too
difficult to stay on Big Brother and
they cut themselves from the show is
there I do we have you ever given up on
anything in your life is there any
chance you're gonna call it one time one
time when I was in ninth grade I was
playing JV baseball I wasn't playing
until I quit so I could go play Little
League but it hurt and I promised myself
I would never never give up again okay I
love that have you reached out to anyone
from past seasons or season 1 of
Celebrity Big Brother for advice or how
to play or well like I said I've only
had a week to prepare really so I had to
tie up a lot of loose ends in this past
week so I didn't really have time the
food situation can be interesting inside
the house are you a cook
are you a cleaner are you a helper will
you eat the slop I'm a helper and I like
to fast and so chances are I probably
going to eat very much really why you're
gonna be fasting and trying to play a
Jedi mind game on people this seems like
a lot going on at one time that's what I
do that's what I do
ok get cleaned out and well it to me
that the whole month I mean in the big
picture the whole month is a great
opportunity to change you know it's have
an opportunity to meditate everyday do
yoga every day it's I like the
confinement it allows me to a bit of a
retreat it's going to be difficult to
meditate when they're 11 other people
and that siren and the bots and you know
I mean those are the best times I
meditate my teacher and say if you can
meditate when there's all this craziness
going on then you're good ok what is
your strategy for winning big brother
you know I've been asked that question a
bunch and I'm sure it's an answer that
you guys get a lot but to be myself and
I think that I'm I'm an interesting
person I'm a kind person I have this
calming influence so I think if I can
manage to be myself when all this chaos
is going on I think
but you're also kind of a fierce
competitor and an athlete a professional
athlete so you're gonna win some
physical you know I think people are
gonna look at you when you walk in and
be like ooh I don't want it to be me and
him at the end because he'll beat me in
the physical that's what they think but
they'll see a football in six years okay
what are you gonna do with all that
money oh good question
so I'm launching a dating app that built
on around astrology helping people
understand themselves better and find a
mate and so if I win I can I can use
this money to start development on my
app now are you single I'm married
you're married okay so you're gonna have
all the single people also how people
that are married I think you know what
happens to a lot of people they get into
a relationship and they're like now what
yeah an astrology is great for helping
people manage manage your relationship
okay well since you're into this tell me
something about an Aquarius
Oh Aquarius is easy Aquarius is the
archetype of the genius duh the tree
means tell me more the rebel rabble yeah
Aquarius is about learning to think for
yourself and there's a need for a query
especially early in life to not become
too dependent on other people because if
you have to think for yourself and your
heart is telling you to go one direction
but the people you care about don't
understand and don't get it Aquarius has
to listen to their heart and go that
direction anyway I feel like RCBS
listening right now because we need a
whole other side website that we can
watch which is just your astrology
readings of everyone in the house I love
this that's good stuff we have to keep
you around for a long time because I
need to see all this content the exact
crime awesome dead don't be too good at
the physical stuff I learned that I
don't want to target on my